comedian Patton Oswald you guys probably
heard about this he took three months
basically the entire summer off of
social media and he explained why in a
Time magazine article that came out this
week in part he said what if the next
fashionable rebellion from whatever
generation rears its head after the
Millennials is to become unlinked only
reachable face-to-face hmm remember how
in the matrix mankind had become
batteries so the machines could just
feed off us well it's happening now just
a hundred forty words at a time I
remember when I got out of college 99 I
was having a conversation with a friend
of mine we were on a bus somewhere and
we were talking about the meaning of
life the whole thing I was smoking a lot
of pot at the time and I told him
everything I thought about life and he
goes dude you just told me the plot to
the matrix but I hadn't seen the matrix
but that's what I was but that's what I
was talking about that we are one day
just gonna be batteries for this it's
gonna become that important because this
needs us to just we make a hundred watts
of energy yeah in each body so there you
go we're already about so it's gonna run
the 5.5 that might be a problem that's
gonna be the problem
you really again if we go tight on these
thumbs you know this is my cross to bear
oh yeah yeah look at that that's it
there's I could eat four of those on the
hour and it's still wouldn't equal this
toe toe jam that's happening right here
it's a giant phone yeah a giant thumb
you're welcome America well we know
we're making the gif out of this week
for the show what do you think though
this unlinked idea that's what you're
talking about that that maybe these this
next generation after you know we have
the nude hack this week and the NSA
we're all so sick of it and yet we love
it but we're also sick of it too that
maybe the next generation is kind of
gonna be like but how will we tell
everyone were unlinking terrific such a
great guy is such a great comedian but I
read that whole article he was like I
took three months off but I checked in
on Facebook I learned and I didn't do
any Twitter but I you know like some of
my friends things that were doing
Kickstarter IndieGoGo so I'm like okay
so we took three months off or we just
kind of lurked for three months and
that's what
so what's the point the point is is that
we are in a digital quicksand yeah and
those of us that are old enough you know
sorry to sound like that guy but I
remember the analog right you know it's
analog if we don't get back to some form
of analog and meeting with people like
the poly yeah you know getting together
face to face and lessening the amount of
times where people pull their stupid
phone to check their stupid what Evers
we're in big trouble
yeah it's generational and the next
generations not gonna without something
major like you know the inability to be
able to transmit because our networks
out electricity going away it's not
gonna get better slightly what you're
doing with the poly because because I
think it's really cool and it's one of
the things that by me being in LA has
allowed me to put this down because I
don't do this when I'm there so can you
just explain a little bit of what you're
doing I just I've been lucky enough to
have an incredible group of artists and
people come into my life comedians
musicians writers people like you and we
hang out we have you know we meet once a
month or so very casual party atmosphere
and we just connect we just connect we
don't we don't we have all these and yes
we'll bring it out we need to Google
something because we do that but it is
it's it's a connection of people and but
even the name itself poly mind okay yeah
so the poly mind came about because I
you know we have all these voices in our
head and I have all the voices in my
head and I originally made it as like a
blog kind of a title the poly mind
commune is the thing in my head and and
what it is is it it is its diversity its
diversity of perspective its diversity
of people and it's it's what makes the
world go round actually and and you know
part of this is that this we've been
talking about the whole show lack of
diversity happens through this because
you pick your Twitter feed you pick your
friends on Facebook and you pick a pick
what channel your news from so you know
and there's something about just hanging
out with people and getting to know
people it's big courting because people
don't understand what's happening
because they're digital they don't
understand the lack of humanity the loss
of human connection
I mean in all sincerity if you ever
wanted to say you wanted to date
somebody you called a girl up on the
phone that still was an analog moment
because she was hearing your voice and
trying to figure out how to get off the
phone as fast as possible with texting
you can be led down that path for longer
because this digital thing is almost a
Santa it's like sanitizing your
interactions so when we kind of get
together as a group like if you go out
to dinner with two other couples or
whatever you think oh well that's social
that's face-to-face but that is such a
small microcosm of what's necessary to
combat what's going on in our society
you've got to get together in groups
hopefully without the try pointed hats
and you know and flip on yeah and and
meet people and bounce from person to
person as opposed to from webpage or
Twitter feed a Twitter feed there's
something we're losing and we're losing
our analog social skills losing it
learning to look in a person's eyes when
you have a conversation and to feel okay
about that is God your eyes are soon
right that's what that's what that's
that study is talking about those kids
are not learning those skills so then 25
30 years down the line how do when you
have two warring sides of two countries
come together to sit in a room to have
to find some common ground and you can't
even really look each other in the eye
one tweet to rule them all I think
that's a great way to wrap it up is we
even see this now with our political
leaders you know Ronnie and Iran
tweeting at the State Department they're
to it but it's like guys maybe in a room
do you like this everyone thinks it's so
great look they're tweeting at each
other it's the greatest thing ever but
actually it's totally totally
meaningless